mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
the following set of equations were put
online by nicolas trotta the education
minister in argentina
like any good math problem this problem
sparked a lot of positive discussion
about how to get the correct answer
i thought i would present a video
showing two different interpretations to
the correct answer
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
there's one way to interpret the problem
using elementary mathematics and that's
the official solution but many people
used advanced mathematics and that's the
interpretation i prefer so i'll go
through both approaches
to get started we'll analyze each
equation in turn
the first equation says three
calculators are equal to 30 which means
one calculator is equal to 10.
the second equation will have ten plus
two books will be equal to eighteen
this means that two of these books will
be equal to eight or one set of books is
equal to four
so far there's no disagreement
we get to the third equation
we now substitute that four minus two of
these laptops is equal to two
this means four minus two is equal to
two laptops or two is equal to two
laptops
here's where the interpretation comes
into play under an elementary
mathematics interpretation these two
laptops represent two separate laptops
you want to add the value of each one
therefore two laptops is equal to two
which means one laptop is equal to one
we then evaluate the final expression
we substitute in the values of one four
and ten
then we remember to multiply four and
ten first by the order of operations so
we get one plus forty and then our final
answer is equal to 41.
this is the official answer
however the way the equation was written
left open to interpretation for some
advanced mathematics
see this equation looks like two laptops
but it actually resembles x to the power
of x
how would you solve the problem in this
interpretation
it's a little bit more tricky
we have to use the lambert w function
to explain this it's the inverse of x
times e to the power of x
so if x times e to the power of x is
equal to some value z
then x is equal to w of z
so how does that help us solve the
problem
we'll first rewrite this equation
for any value x x is equal to e to the
power of the natural log of x
we'll rewrite this equation
then we will take the natural log of
both sides
this simplifies to the following
equation
we then write u for the natural log of x
and the equation becomes u times e to
the power of u is equal to the natural
log of 2.
we can therefore use the lambert w
function on this equation we can solve
that u is equal to w of the natural log
of 2.
and that's equal to the natural log of x
so we take e to the power of that on
both sides and we can solve that x is
equal to e to the power of w of the
natural log of 2.
evaluating the product log we get this
is approximately 1.56 therefore this
becomes the value of one laptop as
before we substitute in the values to
the final expression we multiply 4 and
10 together and we get an approximate
answer of 41.56
either interpretation is correct i
prefer the advanced mathematics
interpretation it adds a little bit more
spice and it helps a lot more people
engage in higher level mathematics
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]
you